[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: All right.
It's 11:05.
I'm going to try to start
promptly at 11:05 each time.
So welcome.
Is everybody psyched?
I'm psyched.
This is 913, the Human Brain.
I'm Nancy Kanwisher.
I'm the prof for this class.
And lest, you were wondering, I
have a brain, and there it is.
That's me, with some
bits colored in that you
will learn about in this class.
OK.
What I'm going to
do today is I'm
going to tell you a brief
story for around 10 minutes.
And then I'm going to
talk about the why, how,
and what studying the human
brain, why it's a cool thing
to do, how you do it,
and what in particular
we're going to
learn about in here,
and then we'll do some mechanics
and details of the course,
and allocation of
grades, and all that.
It's on the syllabus anyway.
Cool?
That's the agenda.
All right.
So let's start with that story.
And for this, I'm
going to sit up here.
The story isn't
that long, but it
has a lot of interesting
little weird bits.
So I have cue cards
to remind myself
of all the bits I want
to remember to say.
So you can put away your
phones and your computers.
And you don't need
to take notes.
This is just a story.
It's going to foreshadow a lot
of the themes in the course,
but it's not stuff you're
going to be tested on.
OK.
So this is a true
story, and I've
changed only a few
tiny little bits
to protect the identity
of the people involved.
But otherwise, it's an
absolutely true story.
It's a story about a
scary medical situation
that happened to a friend
of mine a few years ago.
But at the same
time, it's a story
about the nature
of the human mind,
about the organization
of the human brain.
And it's also a story
about the ability or lack
thereof to recover
after brain damage.
It's also incidentally a story
about resilience, privilege,
expertise, and all
of those things that
are characteristic of many
people in Cambridge society,
not so relevant for the course,
but, all right, here goes.
So a few years ago,
a friend of mine
was staying over at
my house in Cambridge
en route to a conference
in a nearby state.
And this guy, I'll call him
Bob, was a close friend of mine.
I'd known him for
years and years.
We talked regularly.
We went on hiking
trips together.
We were pretty close.
So he's en route
to this conference.
He's staying over at my
house the night before.
The plan was for him to get
up early the next morning
and drive to the conference.
So we hung out the night
before and chatted.
And the next morning, he's
sleeping in the next room
over from mine.
And early in the morning,
I hear some shuffling.
I think yep, OK, Bob is
packing to leave and thank,
God, I don't need to get up.
I'm only dimly awake.
And so I'm not paying
that much attention.
Shuffle, shuffle, shuffle
in the background.
And then I hear a crash.
And I think, what
the hell is that?
And I get up and I go
into the next room.
And Bob is lying on
the floor, not moving.
I say, Bob, and
there's no answer.
And then I shout, Bob,
and there's no answer.
And then I dialed 911.
While we were sitting there
waiting for the ambulance
to arrive, Bob
starts to wake up.
And he's very woozy,
but he's alive.
And he's making a
little bit of sense.
And he can't figure
out what's going on,
and neither can I. And so
we're talking and chatting,
and he's making a
little more sense,
but we still don't
know what's happening.
So then the ambulance
arrives incredibly fast.
I felt like three minutes, boom.
There's three EMTs
rushing in the front door,
rushing up to the
room where Bob was.
And they take all his vitals.
And they can't find
anything wrong.
And so they're really casual.
I guess they confront stuff
like this all the time.
I don't.
Bob doesn't, but they're
very calm about it.
And they're saying,
well, go take him
to the hospital or not.
And I was like, I think we need
to know what just happened,
even though we seems OK.
We kind of need to know
what this is all about.
Don't you think?
They're like, yeah, you
could take him to the ER.
And I said, well, do we need
to waste ambulance resources,
or do you think it's safe if I
drive him myself, since there's
a hospital not far away?
They say you could
drive him yourself.
So I drive Bob to the
Mount Auburn Hospital ER,
which is like less than
a mile from my house.
And we do the usual
ER thing, which
is mostly waiting, and
waiting, and waiting,
but various docs come by.
And they take all these tests.
And they take all these
history questions,
and it goes on and on.
And basically, they're
just not finding anything.
So after about an
hour or two of this,
they're still doing tests.
They don't want to quite
let him go yet, because they
don't know what happened.
Everybody's calm about it.
I figure, OK, fine,
I got work to do.
And I tell, Bob, text
me throughout the day,
and I'll come get you whenever
they're ready to release you.
And so I go into work, but
just before I go into work,
a thought flashes through my
mind, and I say to the ER,
doc you should
check Bob's brain.
And the reason that thought
flashed through my mind
is that actually I had
been worrying about Bob
for a number of years.
And I hadn't really--
it hadn't quite
registered consciously,
It was kind of too horrifying a
thought for me to really allow
myself to realize I was
worried about Bob's brain,
but I was worried about
a very particular thing
and that is that
Bob had been showing
these weird signs
that he often got
lost and didn't
know where he was.
And on the one hand, this
just didn't make any sense,
because he was fine
in every other way,
but it was really
pretty striking.
So one time, I was
over at Bob's house
with some other friends of ours.
And the friend
asked, Bob, how do
we get-- how do I drive from
your house into Cambridge?
And Bob said, well, you go
to the end of the driveway,
and you turn left.
My friend and I looked at
each other like, Bob, what?
And Bob thinks about
it for a minute, yeah,
end of the driveway, turn left.
I just had this like
sinking feeling of dread
in the pit of my stomach, but
we sort of made light of it,
and made fun of
it, and it went by.
It was like, no, you turn right,
and we gave the directions.
Another time a friend
of mine was driving
with Bob in Bob's hometown.
And notice that
like Bob didn't seem
to know how to
get to the grocery
store in his
hometown, where he'd
lived for a really
long time, a trip he'd
made hundreds of times.
Another time, I was at
a conference in Germany.
And I saw there are
these arrays of posters
of people presenting usually
pretty dry scientific things.
And out of the corner of my
I see the title of a poster
and it says navigational
deficits colon,
an early sign of Alzheimer's.
And I saw that,
and I just saw ah,
and I just kind of
suppress the thought.
I thought, oh my God,
Bob, wasn't that old.
I know Alzheimer's can
very rarely strike early.
I didn't want to
think about it, but it
was like rattling around
in the back of back
of my consciousness.
So there had been
these signs, but as I
say, it didn't make sense,
because Bob was holding down
a very high-powered job.
He was writing beautiful prose.
He was the life of every
party he was at witty, funny.
Everybody's like favorite
life of the party.
So how could that be?
It just didn't make sense
that there would be anything
wrong with Bob's brain.
So I managed for a few
years to notice these signs
and ignore them and
not pay any attention.
So the killer thing is, I
should have known better.
My research for the last 20
years has been on the very fact
that there are different
parts of the brain that
do different things.
And one of the
corollaries of that
is you can have a
problem with one
of those parts and the other
parts can work just fine.
And so I, if anyone,
should have realized,
yes, there's something really
wrong with Bob's navigation
abilities.
And the fact that
he's smart, and witty,
and funny and holding
down a high powered job
doesn't mean there isn't
something wrong with his brain,
with a part of his brain.
But I didn't realize that.
But then, as I'm leaving the
ER, theyit kind of all clicked.
And I said to the ER doc,
you better check his brain.
I thought Bob was out of
earshot when I said that.
He heard it.
He's like what?
I was like, oh, never mind.
Anyway, the ER doc with
the kind of confidence
that only docs can muster
said, no, not a brain thing.
This is a heart thing, which
wasn't exactly reassuring,
but I set aside
the brain thought.
And I went off to work.
So throughout the day, I
texted with Bob a few times.
Things seem to be fine.
They've done more tests.
They weren't finding anything.
We just got calmer
and calmer about it.
I guess sometimes weird stuff
happens, and you just move on.
But then that night
around 7:00 or 8:00
at night, I was over
at a friend's house,
and the phone rang.
And it was Bob.
I picked it up and Bob
says, get over here.
They found something
in my brain.
So I ran out of the
house, grabbed my phone.
And as I'm driving to
the Mount Auburn ER,
I called my trusty lab
tech, an amazing guy,
who keeps track of all kinds of
things much better than I do,
and I said, I remember
that we scanned
Bob a bunch of years ago for a
regular experiment in my lab.
And I don't remember the date.
I don't remember anything about
it, but dig around in the files
and see if you
can figure it out.
It might be useful
to have that scan.
So by the time I get
to the ER, my lab tech
has already texted me back
and said found the scans.
I'm putting them in
a Dropbox for you.
So I go into the ER, and
there's Bob and the ER doc.
And Bob says to me,
do you want to see it?
The ER doc or the
radiologist has already
shown Bob the
picture of his brain.
And so they take me in there.
And I look at it.
And I gulped.
There was a thing
the size of a lime
smack in the middle
of his brain.
Pretty terrifying.
So this lime in the
middle of Bob's brain
was right next to a
region that my lab
had studied in great detail.
In fact, my lab had discovered
that a brain region right next
to where that line was
located was specifically
involved in navigation.
How could I not have
put all this together?
But I didn't until that moment
I thought, of course, of course,
there's a thing
in his brain right
next to the parahippocampal
place area, which I discovered,
and a nearby related region
called retrosplenial cortex,
of course.
And how the hell could
I not have known?
But I didn't know.
In that earlier work, it had
been nearly 20 years ago,
I had a postdoc named
Russell Epstein.
And Russell was a
computer vision guy.
And he wanted to understand
how we see by writing code
to duplicate the algorithms
that he thought go on
in the human brain when we
understand visual images.
And that's a very
respectable cool line
of work, which we'll learn
a little bit about in here.
And Russell was
really a coding guy.
At the time, we were just
starting doing brain imaging,
but Russell was like
pooh poohing it all.
It's like the flash in the pan.
It's going to go by.
It's trashy.
So you guys get nice
blobs on the brain.
I'm not having any of it.
And I kept saying, Russell,
you need to get a job.
Just do one experiment so
you can show in your job talk
that you can do brain imaging.
It might help you.
You don't need to
do a lot of it.
Just do one dumb experiment.
Russell was interested in how
we recognize scenes, not just
objects, and faces, and words,
but how do we know where we are
and how do we recognize if the
scene as a city, or a beach,
or whatever it is?
I said, OK, Russell,
we'll just scan people,
looking at pictures
of scenes, and looking
at other kinds of pictures.
And we'll just kind
of see if there's
any part of the brain that
responds a lot to scenes.
It really was not
well thought out.
This is not how you
should do an experiment.
It shouldn't be based on
political calculations, lack
of theory, any of the above.
But the fact is that's why
we did that experiment.
Russell needed to be able to
show a brain image in his job
talk.
So we scan some people
looking at scenes.
And the results
knocked our socks off.
We found a part of the brain
that responds very selectively
when you look at
images of scenes,
not when you look at
faces, objects, words,
or pretty much anything else.
And so we'll learn more about
that later in the course.
We called it the
parahippocampal place area.
And that launched a whole
major line of work in my lab
and now dozens of other
labs around the world.
Backtrack-- we'd already
found that region.
And here's this
lime in my friend
Bob's brain, sitting right next
to the parahippocampal place
area.
Then I remembered, let's
look at the scans from my lab
from a few years
ago in Bob's brain.
I fiddled around and managed
to download the files.
And there it was.
You could see that same blob.
But in the scans
from a few years
before, it was much smaller.
It was the size of a grape.
That told us a bunch of things.
Most importantly, it told us
this thing is growing really
slowly.
And that was hugely important,
because brain tumors
are very bad news.
And they usually
grow really fast.
And the fact that it
grew really slowly
told us that this was not one
of the kind of worst, most
invasive, most horrible ones.
It was clearly a problem.
It was big.
But at least it wasn't
growing hugely fast.
But how poignant that there
was in my own damn data,
and I hadn't seen it
in my friend's brain.
Well, I'm not a radiologist.
I'm a basic researcher.
And I didn't look,
and I didn't see it.
Indeed, the next
day, the docs told us
that they thought this was
meningioma, not cancer.
Who knew that you could have
tumors that weren't cancer?
But you can.
And they still need to come
out, if they're big enough.
And that's very serious.
But it's not as bad as having
a cancer in your brain.
As we're collecting
information, the next day,
I'm hanging out in
the hospital room.
And there was an amusing moment
when one of the residents
came by.
And he's taking the
history and asking
all of the basic questions.
And I said kind of
sheepishly-- because you
don't want to seem like you
know more than the residents.
And in fact, I didn't
really know more,
but I just thought I'd
provide a little information.
And I said, he's actually had
symptoms for a bunch of years,
and there's a
region of the brain
nearby that I've actually
studied a little bit.
And the resident says,
like, we know who you are.
So much for my trying
to stay under the radar.
That afternoon, I talked to a
neurosurgeon friend of mine,
because I figured,
OK, we need advice.
We need help.
And the neurosurgeon
friend said,
quote-- it got
branded in my brain--
she said, "it is of
paramount importance
that you find the
best neurosurgeon.
It's the difference between
whether Bob dies on the table
or goes on to live
a normal life."
This is the privilege
part of the story.
I'm not that well connected,
but I'm a little bit connected.
And I kind of dug around,
and did what I could.
And we spent a couple
of weeks, and we
found the best neurosurgeon.
And the night
before the surgery,
Bob is staying over at my
house, because the surgery
was in a Boston hospital.
And I thought, I've been
dancing around this for years,
but now it's all
out in the open.
We know there's a problem.
And I'm going to test him.
I'm going to find out
what the hell's going on.
This is, after all, one
of the basic forms of data
that we collect
in my field-- that
is, testing people with
problems in their brain
to try to figure out
what things they can do
and what things they can't do.
It's a way of figuring out
what the basic components
of the mind and brain are.
It's actually the oldest, most
venerable method in our field,
and it's still a
hugely important one.
So I thought, what the hell.
So I said, OK, Bob, draw me
a sketch map of the floor
plan of your house.
Bob takes a few minutes
and he draws this thing.
And it was shocking.
There weren't even-- the rooms
in a rectilinearly arranged
house, they weren't
even aligned.
There was, like,
a soup of lines.
There was no organization
from one room to the next.
And Bob kind of realized,
this isn't right, is it?
But he didn't know
how to fix it.
And he said he just
couldn't visualize
what it looked like
to be in his house,
and so he couldn't
draw the floor plan.
And I thought, OK, he hasn't
been there in a couple of days.
So I gave him another
piece of paper
and I said, OK, draw the
floor plan of my house, where
you are right now.
Bob took a couple of minutes
and delivered a similar mess.
He couldn't even imagine
the layout of the room next
to him, that he'd been
in a few minutes before.
And then, trying to channel
my inner neuropsychologist,
I thought OK.
Gave him another
piece of paper and I
said, OK, Bob, draw a bicycle.
Why did I choose a bicycle?
Because it's a
multi-part object that
has a bunch of
different bits that
have a particular
relationship to each other,
just as the rooms
in a house have
a particular spatial
relationship to each other.
And I wanted to know, is
his problem specifically
about places, or is it about
any complex, multi-part thing
that you have to remember
the relationships to?
Bob is no artist,
to put it mildly.
But his bicycle was clearly
recognizable as a bicycle.
It had the two wheels in
the right relationship,
and it had all of
the basic parts
in roughly the right place.
I then had him draw a lobster,
another multi-part object.
And also, his lobster
was not beautiful,
but had everything
in the right place.
That's very telling he had
a specific problem in--
I don't know-- imagining,
reproducing, remembering?
It's not totally clear.
The arrangements
of parts in a room,
but not the arrangements
of parts in an object.
And we'll get back to
that more in a few weeks.
What do I want to say here?
I said all of that.
The next day, Bob has
an 11-hour surgery.
Major, hardcore,
extreme neurosurgery.
Remove a huge piece of bone
from the back of your head,
pull apart the hemispheres
of the brain like this,
go in multiple inches
and remove a lime.
Holy crap, right?
Said lime was right
near the vein of Galen.
Galen lived, what, a couple
of thousand years ago?
The fact that there's
a vein of Galen
means it's a big-ass
vein-- the kind of vein
that even Galen would
have found with dissection
2,000 years ago.
This lime was all wrapped
around and interleaved
with the vein of Galen.
Not good.
But because we found
the best neurosurgeon,
and because we have
extreme privilege and all
of the possible
medical resources
and expertise you could
possibly hope for,
Bob sailed through the surgery.
And an hour after the
surgery, I'm chatting with him
and he's making sense.
Amazing, right?
And literally, two days
later, they sent him home.
And a few days after
that, he's back at work.
No problem.
Totally fine.
But now we get to the question
you're probably thinking about.
What about his
navigational abilities?
The sad answer
is, nothing doing.
None of it came back at all.
Thank god for iPhones.
If Bob lived 30 years ago, he
wouldn't be able to function.
But he goes everywhere
using his iPhone GPS--
everywhere.
And this fact that
he didn't recover
his navigational
abilities is consistent
with the whole
literature that we'll
consider later in the course--
that, often-- not
always, but often,
if you have brain
damage, especially
to some of these
very specialized
circuits that we'll talk
about, you don't recover later.
If the damage is early, you may
well recover-- early in life,
you may well recover.
Children have much more
plastic brains that
can adjust after brain damage.
Adults, not so good.
Bob's doing fine.
That's my story.
Any thoughts or questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can he tell the
difference between right
to left [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
Yes.
And it's very interesting.
There are many of his
spatial abilities that
are absolutely intact, and yet
the ones related to navigation
are not.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can he drive?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, no problem.
But he's always looking at his
damn phone to get directions,
or to listen to the
GPS directions system.
Driving is no problem.
It's another kind of
left-right-- the immediate
spatial orientation abilities
are absolutely fine.
But knowing, where am I now,
and how would I get there
from here, is blitzed.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can he
recognize familiar places?
NANCY KANWISHER: Great question.
Yes, he can recognize
familiar places.
What he can't do is,
he can say, oh, right,
that's the front of
our house, or that's
such-and-such cafe
that's near our house.
What he can't do
is say, which way
would you turn from
there to go home?
AUDIENCE: Can he can he string
together multiple [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Great question.
Great question.
A little bit.
He can navigate a
little bit with his GPS.
And because he's
learned certain routes
as a series of almost
verbal commands--
if you're here, turn right,
then there, nur, nur, nur, nur.
That whole kind of thing.
It's not what any of
you guys could do.
If you guys are driving
around in Cambridge
or walking around campus--
remember when they blocked off
this whole middle of campus
a couple of years ago?
It was so irritating.
I would like go there,
and it's like, oh god,
they've blocked it off.
I can't get over to lobby 7.
Well, you immediately come
up with an alternate route.
It's like, OK, I guess we're
going to have to do this.
You come up with
an alternate route.
This is a normal
navigation system can do.
Bob can't do that at all.
He's like, route blocked?
No idea.
Get out the phone.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is he good at
estimating distances?
Does he know something is
a certain number of miles
away, or?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
Yes, he is.
And that's very interesting.
But that seems to be kind
of a different thing.
You could think about all of
the different kinds of cues
you have for distance beyond
your kind of literal navigation
skills.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: A little bit.
A couple of minutes, yes.
The next day--
I mean, it would be
kind of like this thing.
It's like, I sort of vaguely
remember that when I was here,
I turned right, so I'd
better do that again.
Yes, did you have question?
AUDIENCE: Can he navigate
within buildings?
NANCY KANWISHER:
No, not very well.
And this is a problem, because
iPhones don't usually-- yeah.
New hotels, big problem.
Finding the bathroom down
the hall, or the front door
in a hotel, big problem.
Yeah.
I mean, these are
problems you can--
you can come up
with workarounds.
It's not life-threatening, but
it's extremely inconvenient.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it the case that
those navigational skills that
develop long-term, like a
long time ago are stronger?
So he has a harder
time developing--
for example, you said
new hotels are a problem.
But if it is places that are
more familiar, like his home,
is it easier for
him to navigate?
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
a great question.
And you might
think that the kind
of navigational maps you laid
down long ago would be intact.
So is it just that you
can't learn new ones?
It's a great question.
The answer is kind of
complicated in this case.
For routes that he's memorized--
there's a whole different
system for knowing a route,
and really having an
abstract knowledge
of a place that enables you to
devise a new route if something
is blocked on that route.
For highly over-learned
routes, he's OK.
He remembers the [INAUDIBLE].
It's like a memorized
motor sequence.
You do A, and then B,
and then C, and then D.
He's OK with those, with
routes he learned long ago.
But he is not good at coming
up with a new route in a place
that he learned long ago.
We'll take one last question.
AUDIENCE: Does he
have conscious access
to past knowledge
that [INAUDIBLE]
And does he have conscious
knowledge that [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: No, he knows--
well, he knows,
because when he tries
to figure out which way
to head, he has no idea.
He's extremely aware of
it, and very articulate
on precisely what happens.
What he says is, if he's
looking at a place--
here's something he says.
He's looking at a place.
He knows where he
is, because there's
all kinds of other
bits of information
that tell you where you
are, because you intended
to go there, and the relevant
things are happening, and all.
So he knows where he is.
And it looks familiar.
If he tries to imagine
what's behind him,
he says that he starts to get it
and it just kind of vaporizes.
He just can't hang on to it.
He can't kind of construct
a stable mental image
of nearby places.
I don't know exactly
what that means,
but he's very articulate,
and can report what happens--
what he experiences
when he tries to access
this kind of information.
What you guys-- we'll go on.
But what I want to say
is, what you guys just
did is exactly what
we do in my field.
We try to take a mental
ability and tease it apart
and say, is it exactly
this or is it exactly that?
And you guys all just
did it beautifully.
A lot of what we
do in my field is
kind of this common-sense
parsing of mental abilities.
What is a particular
mental ability--
how does it relate
to some other one?
Are these things separable ?
Can you lose one
and not the other?
Do they live in different
parts of the brain, et cetera?
All right.
That's the story.
I'm going to cache out some
of the particular themes that
came out from the story that
will echo through this course.
And the first and
most obvious one
is, the brain isn't just
a big bunch of mush.
It has structure.
It has organization.
The different bits
do different things.
Importantly, when Bob had
this big lime in his head,
he didn't just get
a little bit stupid.
No.
His IQ, if he'd take an IQ
test, would be unchanged.
He lost a very specific
mental ability.
And that is fascinating,
but it's also
good news for science.
Because often, when you try to
understand a complicated thing,
a great way to make progress
is to first figure out
what the parts are, and then
later try to figure out,
how does each
individual part work
and how do they work together?
But if there's part
structure, there's
at least a place to start.
Second theme is that
some parts of the brain
do extremely specific things.
Not all of them.
Some of them are
quite general, and are
engaged in lots of
different mental processes.
But some are
remarkably specific.
We'll talk a lot about that.
Third big theme.
The organization of the
brain echoes the architecture
of the mind.
And I would say, the
fundamental pieces of the brain
are telling us what are
fundamental parts of the mind.
And that's why
I'm in this field.
That's what I think is cool.
The brain is just
a bunch of cells.
It's a physical thing.
Who cares about
a physical thing?
The reason we care about it is,
that's where our mind lives.
And if we study
that physical thing,
we can learn something
about our minds.
And that's pretty
cosmic, I think.
The point of all of
this kind of work
is not to say, oh, that mental
process is here, not there.
Who cares?
I don't really care.
I mean, at some point, you
need to have a ballpark sense.
You need to know to
study the things.
But the interesting
question is not
where these things
are in the brain,
but which mental processes
have their own specialized
machinery, and why those?
Another important theme.
How do brains change?
Bob didn't recover
after his brain damage,
in that very particular
mental function that he lost.
If all of that had happened
when he was five years old,
he probably would have.
How do brains change
over normal development?
How do they change from
learning and experience?
How do they change after injury?
And the final theme
echoed in that story
is, there are lots and
lots of different ways
to study the brain.
There are the simple
behavioral observations.
Bob can't navigate, but
he can do everything else.
OK, that's really deep and
informative-- low-tech,
but really powerful.
The anatomical brain
images that showed
where the lime was
in Bob's brain,
that gives you another
kind of information.
What's the physical
structure of the brain?
The functional
images that we had
done in my lab to discover the
parahippocampal place area,
and the studies of what
mental abilities are preserved
and which are lost
in people who have
alterations of their brain.
Those are just a
few of the kinds
of methods in our
field, each of which
tells us about a different
kind of thing about the brain.
Those are the themes I
was trying to get at here.
Let's move on to the
why, how, and what
of exploring the brain.
I'm going to assign the TAs
to get me to shut up at--
let's see.
We're supposed to
end at 5 minutes
before the end of
class, is that right?
Is that the MIT tradition?
OK, so at-- oh, my,
shockingly soon--
11:45, you're going to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
great, thank you.
Thank you.
This is one of the many
things TAs are for.
They pick up the hundreds
of typos and "mindos"
and all of that.
Excellent.
I'm thinking, how the hell
did I so mis-time this?
Thank you, Heather.
OK, good.
We'll go on.
Why should we study the brain?
First, most obvious
reason, know thyself.
Know what this thing is
that's operating in our heads.
This is who you
are, is your brain.
There are lots of very fine and
important organs in the body,
but the brain is special.
So, a heart is important.
You'd die without it.
But it's the brain
that's your identity.
There's a reason that
surgeons do heart transplants.
That makes sense.
Something wrong with your heart,
you need another heart, OK.
But why don't they
do brain transplants?
That wouldn't make sense.
If there's something
wrong with my brain,
it doesn't make sense to
take someone else's brain
and put it in here, because
then I'd be that other person.
It doesn't make sense, because
the brain is who you are.
So the brain is really special.
It's not just another organ.
That's why, a few years ago, we
had the decade of the brain--
not the decade of the pancreas,
or the liver, or the kidney.
People need to
study these things.
They need to know
how to fix them.
They're important.
But they're not as
cosmic as the brain.
Second reason why we
should understand brains,
and that is to understand the
limits of human knowledge.
The more we understand
about the human mind,
the more we can
actually evaluate
how good our knowledge is.
Are there things that we
might not be able to think?
Possible through
scientific theories
we might not be able
to understand, ever?
You can think of
studying the mind
as a kind of empirical
epistemology, a way
to actually know
about the knower
so we can figure out how
good the knowledge is
in that knower.
That's another reason.
A third reason is to advance AI.
Up until a few years ago, I
used to give lectures on vision,
and they would all start
with some version of this.
You guys all have amazing
visual abilities in the back
of your brain that does vision.
You can do all of
this incredible stuff
that no machine can touch.
Hats off to you.
You have an amazing
visual system back here,
and those guys in AI--
it is mostly guys.
Guys, gals, whatever.
Those people in AI
could only dream
of coming up with
algorithms as good
as the one that's running
in the back of your head.
You can't quite start the
lectures that way anymore.
If any of you have
been living in a cave
and not heard about
deep nets, there's
been a massive revolution.
And all of a sudden,
deep nets are
doing things that are really
close to human abilities,
particularly in vision.
For example, in visual
object recognition,
machines were way far
behind human vision
until very recently, especially
when this paper here came out--
was published in 2012.
First author, Krizhevsky.
It has now been cited an
astonishing 33,000 times.
Actually made this slide
a couple of weeks ago.
It's probably been cited
36,000 times by now.
You could look it up on
Google Scholar and find out.
That is a huge
number of citations.
The influence of this
paper is ginormous.
Probably half of you have
already heard about this paper.
Raise your hand if you've
heard about this paper.
Oh, OK.
All right.
Major, big news.
What's so important
about this paper?
Well, they trained-- as,
probably, most of you
know-- they trained a deep net
on the over 1 million images
in ImageNet, a massive
computer database of images.
And they basically taught
it to do object recognition.
And it performed
much more accurately
than any previous system, and
it approaches human abilities.
This is major.
This is a radical
change in the situation
that we were in five years ago.
Things have changed radically.
Just as an example,
here's one of the figures
from that seminal paper.
Here is one of the
images from ImageNet
that AlexNet, this trained
network, was tested on.
And the correct answer,
according to ImageNet,
is that that's a mite.
And here's what AlexNet says.
Its number one first
answer is mite,
and its second,
third, fourth answers
are black widow,
cockroach, et cetera.
Pretty damn good.
The mite is even sticking
off the edge of the frame,
and it gets it.
Container ship.
First choice, container ship.
Pretty good.
Second choice makes sense.
Lifeboat.
Not bad.
Look at that-- motor scooter.
I can barely even see the
motor scooter in there,
but AlexNet, awesome.
Right?
Leopard.
Awesome.
Even when AlexNet
makes a mistake,
the mistake is totally
understandable.
Like, according to ImageNet,
that is a picture of a grille,
and AlexNet calls
it a convertible.
I'm siding with
AlexNet on this one.
This, the correct
answer is mushroom,
and AlexNet says agaric.
I had to look that up.
It's a particular
kind of mushroom.
This one's pretty funny.
ImageNet says that's
pictures of cherry.
There's cherries
in the foreground.
But AlexNet says dalmatian.
I'm siding with AlexNet on this.
And Madagascar cat, et cetera.
Pretty amazing.
And nothing even close to
this was possible before 2012.
This is very recent history,
and it has totally shaken up
the field in lots of ways.
That's been transformative
not just for computer science,
but it's also been
transformative
for cognitive science
and neuroscience.
Because now, we have
algorithms-- like,
here's this deep net,
and it does this thing.
That's a possible theory
of how humans do it.
It's a possible,
computationally precise theory
of what's going on in here.
And we didn't use to
have those, and now we
have those for a
number of domains.
And that's shaking up the field.
There will be a whole
lecture on deep nets
and how you can use them
to think about minds
and brains toward the end of
the course-- guest lecture
by my postdoc Katharina Dobbs.
And we'll hear more about that.
But let's first
step back a second
and say, OK, do they really
perform as well as humans, even
on just object recognition?
Well, what if we tested it
on images not in ImageNet?
ImageNet is a pretty good test
because these things, as you
can see, are highly variable.
They have backgrounds.
They're complicated.
They're real-world images.
But they were photographs taken
by people in a particular way,
with a particular goal.
And most of the photographs
you take, you throw out.
They don't end up in ImageNet.
ImageNet is a weird little
idiosyncratic subset
of the kind of visual
experience that we have.
So would this really generalize?
It so happens that Boris
Katz and Andrei Barbu,
across the street in
CSAIL, have been doing
some very interesting studies.
This stuff isn't published
yet, but I got their permission
to tell you about this
cool stuff they're doing.
And they're saying,
hey, let's test
AlexNet and other similar
deep nets since then on a more
Realistic, harder version
of object recognition
that's more characteristic
of what humans do.
They're generating this
huge data set of stimuli
that they crowdsource.
Workers on Mechanical
Turk go on there
and create images for them.
They get instructions
like, hold an object
in this particular
location, or at this angle,
or move it here, and
send us the images.
They are getting, I think,
hundreds of thousands of images
to test this on.
And they're much more
variable in the location
of the object in the image, and
its orientation, and so forth.
For example, you
guys have no problem
telling what that
thing is, but it's
a slightly atypical example.
Likewise, what's the
object on the floor there?
You can tell what
it is, but it's
a slightly atypical example.
What Boris and
Andrei are finding
is that human
performance is still
pretty good on these
images, but the deep nets
are terrible at this stuff.
ResNet, one of the
more recent ones,
drops from 71% correct
on ImageNet to around 25%
correct on these images.
And the other similar,
fancy, more recent networks,
do similarly badly.
On the one hand,
AI, the deep nets,
are awesome and transformative.
No question about it.
But on the other hand,
despite all the hype,
they're still not quite like
human object recognition.
They're a whole lot closer
than they used to be,
but they're not really there.
And more generally, what
about harder problems,
like image
understanding-- not just
labeling and classification,
but understanding
what's going on in the image?
You guys have probably
seen image captioning bots.
There are lots of
these around now.
This kind of hit
the scene in 2016,
when Google AI came out
with a captioning algorithm.
And of course, right
around the same time,
Microsoft had a
captioning algorithm.
And let's see how they do.
This is an example.
You give this algorithm
this picture here,
and it says, that's a dinosaur
on top of a surfboard.
That's pretty damn good, right?
OK, wow.
Let's look more generally,
how well this thing
works at other examples.
It looks at this
and it says, that's
a group of people on the
field playing football.
Like, wow.
OK.
A snow-covered field.
Pretty good.
Liu Shiwen and Ding Ning
posing for a picture.
I don't know, but
these things are
very good at face recognition.
That's probably exactly
those two people.
A car parked in a parking lot.
Pretty good.
A large ship in the water.
A clock tower lit up at night.
Awesome, right?
A vintage photo of a pond.
Well, the vintage part.
I don't know where the pond is.
There's a little water in there.
I don't know.
Not way off.
A group of people
that are standing
in the grass near a bridge.
Not really.
There's grass.
There's a bridge, sort of.
There's people.
But not really, right?
A group of people
standing on top of a boat.
Definitely not.
A building with a cake.
What?
A person holding a cell phone.
Not.
A group of stuffed animals.
I love this one.
A necklace made of bananas.
Wow.
We've really landed
on Mars here.
A sign sitting on the grass.
Talk about missing the boat.
Now, look at this
picture for a second.
Just figure out
what's going on here.
Takes a couple of seconds.
Everyone got it?
There's a lot going on here.
This algorithm
says, I think it's
a group of people standing next
to a man in a suit and tie.
And the algorithm is
correct, but the algorithm
has profoundly missed the boat.
I'm channeling--
actually, I stole
these slides from
Josh Tenenbaum.
But let me channel
him for a moment
and say what his big
idea is, which I think
is really important.
And that is that both
humans and deep nets
are very good at pattern
recognition-- pattern
classification.
This is a cat, or a dog,
or a car, or a toaster.
What they're not good at--
what humans are good at,
but the deep nets are not,
is building models to
understand the world.
When you look at
this picture, there
are all kinds of things
that are crucial for really
understanding, at a deep
level, what's going on in here.
We need to know
why some people--
what some people here know,
but the guy on the scale
does not know.
Namely, even if
you don't recognize
that that's James Comey--
I think it is--
here's Obama with his
foot on the scale.
You need to know that
people find it embarrassing
if they weigh too much.
You need to know that he can't
see that Obama's doing it.
You need to know
that they can see it,
even though he can't, and that's
kind of the essence of humor.
There's just a whole universe
of rich structural information
going in here that is
part of what it means
to understand this picture.
And no deep net is even close
to doing that kind of thing.
Bottom line of all this is--
or let me just go
on more generally--
AI systems can't
navigate new situations,
infer what others believe,
use language to communicate,
write poetry and music
to express how they feel,
or create math to
build bridges, devices,
and lifesaving medicines.
That's a quote from our
leader, Jim DiCarlo,
head of this department,
published in Wired
a year ago in a beautiful
article on the limitations
of deep nets.
But more generally,
the point is that, yes,
AI is taking a massive leap now.
We're right in the middle of
it, and it's super exciting,
and it's helpful to neuroscience
and cognitive science.
But AI has a lot to
learn from us too--
a lot to learn from
what's going on in here,
and how this thing works
that those AI systems
still can't touch.
All of that was my third
reason for studying--
we're still in the, why are
we studying the human brain?
The fourth reason to
study the human brain
is the one most
compelling to me,
and that is that it is
just simply the greatest
intellectual quest of all time.
We could fight about cosmology.
I'm not going to fight with
you about anything else.
I don't think
there's any contest.
It's the greatest intellectual
quest of all time.
And that's why I'm
in it, and that's
why I hope it'll be fun for you.
That was the why.
How are we going to
study the human brain?
Here's this thing.
How are we going to
figure out how it works?
Kind of daunting,
not totally obvious.
The first thing to
realize is that there
are lots of levels of
organization in this thing,
and hence, lots of
ways of studying it.
We could look at molecules
and their interactions.
Lots of people in
this building do that.
We could look at properties
of individual neurons.
We could look at
circuits of neurons
interacting with each other.
We could look at
entire brain regions
and what their functions are.
We could look at networks
of multiple brain regions
interacting with each other.
All of those things
are possible.
But actually, what we're
going to do in the course
is none of those
things in particular.
Instead, we're going to ask a
somewhat different question.
And that question is,
how does the brain
give rise to the mind?
And to understand
that question, we're
going to do more at this level,
and less at the upper level.
To answer this question, we
need to start with the mind.
We need to-- if we're
going to understand,
how does this thing produce a
mind, we need to first figure
out, what is a mind?
What do we know about minds?
We need to start with the
various mental functions
that minds carry out-- things
like perception, vision,
hearing, aspects of cognition,
like understanding language,
thinking about people, thinking
about things, et cetera.
For each mental function,
what we're going to do in here
is start by trying to
understand how it works in minds
as well as we can, or what it is
that we're trying to understand
that minds can do.
What is computed and how?
And then we're going to
look at its brain basis
and try to figure out
what we can figure out
about how that mental function
is implemented in a brain.
The first question we'll
ask for all of these domains
is, is there specialized
machinery to do that thing?
And then we'll ask,
what information
is represented in the
relevant parts of the brain,
and when is that information
represented, and how?
How are we going to
answer those questions?
Well, there's lots and lots
of methods in our field.
The first set of methods-- if
we want to understand minds,
the first set of methods
are the basic stuff
of cognitive science,
psychophysics.
That means showing
people visual stimuli,
or playing them
sounds, and asking them
what they see or hear.
Nice and low tech,
but lots has been
learned from those methods.
You collect reaction
time and accuracy,
and it's amazing
how much you can
learn from these methods
that have been around
for a hundred years or more.
Perceptual illusions are
similarly very informative
about how minds work.
Now, let me say an important
thing that arises here.
Last year was the first
time I taught this course,
and I would say it went so-so.
I'm aiming for it to be
much better this year.
And one of the ways
I'm trying to do
that is to be responsive
to the student
evals I got last
year, which were not
fabulous across the board.
Hurt my feelings badly.
But once I got over myself, I
decided to just listen to them
and try to fix it.
And one way to fix it is
to be honest with you today
about what this course
is going to cover.
In my evals, student
50458, bless them,
offered this comment.
"This class was not
sold in the correct way.
It should not be
called the Human Brain,
because it was basically
just a cognitive science, not
a brain class.
I expect it to learn
very different material."
I don't know who
this student is.
I wish I could
apologize to them.
But I will say to you,
sorry, student 50458--
sorry I didn't make that clear.
The fundamental the
reason the brain is cool
is that gives rise to the mind.
And that means that studying
the biological properties
of the brain without considering
the mental functions it
implements it would
be kind of like trying
to study the physical
properties of a book
without considering the
meaning of its text.
We're going to
spend a lot of time
doing cognitive science in here.
And if you had a different
impression, sorry about that.
But that's what
we're doing here.
How are we going to answer this?
Lots of cognitive science.
How are we going to
look at the brain basis?
Well, we're going to look at
neuropsychology patients--
people like Bob who
have damage to the brain
and what functions get
preserved and lost.
We'll look at a lot of
studies with functional MRI.
Neurophysiology,
where you can record
from individual neurons
in animal brains,
and in rare cases,
even in human brains--
under clinical
situations where they
need to have electrodes in their
brain anyway for neurosurgery.
We will look at EEG recorded
from electrodes on the scalp
and MEG recording
from magnetic fields
from squids placed
next to the scalp.
We'll look at
connectivity measures
with a method called diffusion
tractography, et cetera.
Lots of methods.
Which mental functions
will we cover?
Well, to tell you
about that, I need
to tell you about the
huge progress that
has happened in our field
in the last 20 years.
All of this is quite recent.
Let's back up to 1990.
Here is approximately what we
knew about the organization
of the human brain in 1990.
The black ovals
are the bits that
are primary sensory and motor
regions that have been known
for a long time, even by 1990.
And the colored
bits are the bits
where we had some idea
that face recognition might
go on somewhere in the
back end of the bottom
of the right hemisphere
because of people
who had damage back there and
lost their face recognition
ability--
sometimes, preserving
their ability
to visually recognize words
and scenes and objects,
only losing their ability
to recognize faces.
The language
regions we had known
about for nearly 200 years,
from Broca and Wernicke
and others, who had studied
patients with damage
in those regions and noted
that they had problems
with language function.
And similarly, many
people had reported
that if you have damage up
here in the parietal lobes,
you sometimes lose
your ability to direct
your attention to different
places in the visual scene.
That was approximately
what was known in 1990.
And here's what we know now.
We now know, thanks
largely to functional MRI,
that for dozens of regions in
the brain, in every one of you,
we have a pretty good idea of
the function of that region.
This is major progress.
This is a kind of rough
sketch of the organization
of the human mind and
brain that we have now,
that we didn't
have 20 years ago.
And that's awesome.
That has made possible
a lot of progress,
building with other methods.
What we'll study
in this course is,
we'll focus on those
mental functions
where the brain bases
are best understood.
And that will include things
like the visual perception
of color, shape, and motion,
visual recognition of faces,
places, bodies, and words--
and scenes.
Didn't make it on the slide.
Oh, yes, it did.
Perceiving scenes
and navigating.
Understanding numbers.
Yes, there's a whole
lot about the brain
basis of understanding numbers.
Perceiving speech
and perceiving music.
Understanding language.
Understanding other
people and their minds.
Those are the kinds of
topics where there's
been a lot of progress recently
in understanding the brain
basis of those mental functions.
Those are the ones
we'll focus on.
And that means there's going
to be a lot on perception,
high-level vision and
high-level audition,
because that's one where a
lot of progress has been made,
and it's also a
lot of the cortex.
As I mentioned a moment ago,
the whole back part your brain
does vision, construed broadly.
Some people might say,
well, why is she spending
all of this time in vision?
Well, it's a big part
of what your brain does.
We are very visual animals.
So we'll spend a lot
of time on vision.
For each of these functions,
we will ask, to what extent
is this mental
function implemented
in its own specialized
brain machinery?
Are there multiple
different brain regions
that carry out that function?
What does each one do?
Is there a division
of labor between
those different regions?
How does that system
arise in development?
Does it have homologues
in other species?
Are these things uniquely
human, or which of them are?
And also, along
the way, other side
cool questions
that will come up.
What, if anything, is special
about the human brain?
How come we are taking over--
and largely destroying--
the planet, and other
species are not?
Besides destroying
the planet, we're
doing some other cool things,
like inventing science,
and engineering, and medicine,
and architecture, and poetry,
and literature, and
all of these other--
and music-- all of these
other awesome things
that other species aren't doing.
How come our brains are doing
that and other species aren't?
Where does knowledge come from?
You guys know all of this stuff.
How much of that stuff was wired
in at birth and how much of it
did you get from experience?
How much can our minds and
brains change over time?
Can we go study a new thing
and get a whole new brain
region for that thing?
Can we change the basic
structure just by training,
or after brain damage?
Can we think without language?
How many of you have
wondered about that question?
Yeah, really basic question.
Anya is answering it.
Anya and some others.
But Anya is doing a lot
to answer that question.
There are actually
empirical answers
to these long-standing,
deep questions
that everyone wonders about.
That's pretty cool.
Somebody back there asked a
while ago about awareness.
Can we think, perceive,
understand without awareness?
How much can go on in
the basement of the brain
when we don't even know
what's going on down there?
We'll consider all of
these other cool questions.
There's a bunch of things we
won't cover in this course
for various reasons, that could
have been in here and just
aren't.
There's only so much time.
Motor control.
It's really important to know
how you do things like pick up
objects and plan actions.
And we're just
not covering that.
Something had to go.
Subcortical function.
This is a very
corticocentric course.
Most of the course will
deal with the cortex.
That's where most of conscious
thinking and reasoning
and cognition happens.
There's a lot of good stuff down
in the basement of the brain,
and it's going to get
pretty short shrift.
Not for any good reason--
just what it is.
Decision-making.
Important field, not getting
much coverage in here.
Importantly,
circuit-level mechanisms--
explanations of cognition.
If you think that we're going
to understand not only what
it means to understand
the meaning of a sentence,
but that I'm going
to give you a wiring
diagram of the neurons that
implement that function,
sorry to be the
bearer of bad news,
but nobody has a
freaking clue how
you could get a bunch
of neurons to understand
the meaning of a sentence.
That's exciting.
That means there's a field
for you guys to waltz into.
And probably, in your
lifetimes, people
will start to
crack these things.
But just to know what
we're headed into,
rarely, for almost no
high-level mental functions,
do we have anything
like a wiring
diagram-level understanding
of any perceptual or cognitive
function.
That's not in the
cards for this course,
because it doesn't
exist in the field.
For that kind of
thing, there are cases
where you can make progress.
You can understand, say,
fear conditioning in a mouse.
Those circuits are
being like cracked wide
open by people in this building,
people all around the world,
with spectacular precision.
They know the specific classes
of neurons, their connectivity.
They know every damn
thing about them.
But it's like, how does a mouse
learn that this thing is--
to be afraid of this thing?
OK, that's important.
But for more complex aspects
of cognition in humans,
we can't usually have that kind
of circuit-level understanding.
Lots of other things that
will get short shrift.
Memory, not for any good reason.
I mean, there's
a lot of coverage
of memory in 900 and 901,
and it's just somehow
off a blind spot
for understanding--
for knowing how to talk
interestingly about memory.
So I'm not going to give you
a boring lecture on memory.
Instead, I'm not going to
give you any lecture on memory
until I learn how to talk
about it interestingly.
Reinforcement learning
and reward systems.
I'm going to try to
pull some of that in,
but it's not going to
be a major focus, even
though it's a really
important part of cognition.
Attention.
There might be some at the end.
How many of you have taken 900?
Looks like a little over a half.
How many have taken 901?
Yeah, a little over half.
OK, good.
If you have, great.
Good for you.
This course is designed as
a tier two course for people
who have taken 900 or 901.
If you haven't,
you're probably OK,
but you might need to
do a little extra work.
I've already posted online, and
in the syllabus, information
about, actually, a
lecture I gave a year ago
on some of the background
stuff that is no longer taught
in this course.
People hated it
when I taught them
stuff they'd already
encountered before,
so I'm trying to minimize that.
That's a backup for
those of you who
haven't taken these courses.
If you're worried about this,
chat with me afterwards.
I think it will
be OK, just count
on doing a little bit of
extra work-- not much.
For those of us
who have taken it,
there's going to be a
little bit of overlap.
It's simply impossible
to have zero overlap.
I mean, what does John Gabrieli
in 900 and Mark Bear in 901 do?
They survey the
whole broad field,
and they pick the coolest
stuff out of every little bit,
and they teach it to you,
exactly as they should.
But that means that when I
come along and try to say,
I'm going to do a more intensive
coverage of the coolest things,
there's going to be a
teeny bit of overlap.
But I'll try to not
make it too much--
just because the coolest
stuff is the coolest stuff.
Also, the spin and the
goals of this course
are quite different
from both 900 and 901.
You will have to memorize
a few things, but not much.
My real goal in this
course is to have
you understand
things, not memorize
a sea of disjointed facts.
A little more on the goals.
Really, what I want you
to get out of this course
is to appreciate the big
questions in the field
and what is at stake
theoretically in each.
I want you to understand the
methods in human cognitive
neuroscience, what
each one can tell you,
what it can't, how different
combinations of methods
Can work synergistically and
complementarily to answer
different facets of a question.
I do want you to gain some
actual knowledge about some
of the domains of
cognition where
we've learned a bunch,
both at the cognitive level
and the brain level--
things like face
recognition, navigation,
language understanding,
music, stuff like that.
And crucially, I
want you guys to be
able to read current
papers in the field.
If you look in the syllabus,
the first few papers
are, like, 20
years old, but it's
going to accelerate quickly
and you'll be reading papers--
I'm trying to choose
mostly papers published
in the last year or two.
I'm trying to take you
straight to the cutting
edge of the field.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are the papers
going to be straight out
of research labs, or are
they going to be, like,
the annual review [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: No, straight
out of research labs.
You're going to
read the real deal,
not someone else's blurry,
they just read the abstracts
and put in some stuff
in the review article.
No, you're going to
read the actual paper.
That's the whole deal.
Those are the goals.
Good.
A few things.
Why no textbook?
This field is moving
too fast for a textbook.
Plus, I have strong
opinions, and I don't
like any of the textbooks.
Any textbook is out of date.
We're going to be reading hot
stuff that's hot off the press,
and so that's not in
the textbooks yet.
And so we're skipping
that, and you're
going to go straight to
original research articles.
There will be occasional
review articles where relevant,
but mostly, part of the
agenda of this course
is to teach you to be not
afraid of and able to read
current articles in the field.
All right.
You've all been
waiting for this.
Details on the grading.
Pretty standard.
Midterm, 25% of the class--
of the grade.
Final, 25%.
It will be cumulative,
but weighted
toward the second half.
There's going to be a lot
of reading and writing
assignments, approximately
two papers to read per week.
And for, usually, one of
those papers per week,
you will have a very short
written assignment in which,
usually, I ask a few simple
questions and maybe one
paragraph-level think question.
The essence of
these tasks is not
the written assignment itself.
The essence of the task is
to understand the paper.
If you understood the
paper as you read it,
then you should be able to
answer those questions pretty
straightforwardly.
And let me just say
that understanding
a scientific paper
is not trivial.
When I write a scientific
paper, right in my area,
where I have all of the
background, it takes me hours--
hours.
It may be five pages.
It still takes me hours.
It's just how it is.
So when I assign a paper and you
say, oh, it's only three pages,
I could do that in 20 minutes.
Oh, no, you can't.
No, you can't.
And that's part of what I
want you to learn how to do,
is how to really
read and understand
the scientific paper.
Allocate the time it
takes to really get it.
That's a big part of
the agenda in this task.
All of the stuff--
the assignments and the
submission of the assignments--
will all happen on Stellar.
Your first written
response to a paper
is due February 12 at
6:00 PM on Stellar.
But there are other readings
that are assigned before that.
A note about the schedule.
I struggled a lot trying to
both have the assignments happen
when you had already learned
enough in lectures to know how
to do it, but have it close
enough to the topic at hand
so it didn't seem, like,
no longer relevant.
It's hard to do both
of those things.
So the compromise is,
all of the assignments
are due at 6:00 PM the
night before the class
in which they're assigned.
If you see that it's
assigned on the 13th--
if it's listed on the lecture
for the 13th, check carefully.
It's probably due
the night of the--
I'm getting this
wrong-- the 12th.
The night before.
And that's so that we and
the TAs can look at it,
figure out what you understood,
what you didn't, and how
to incorporate and
explain whatever you
didn't get in the next lecture.
All right.
Quizzes.
I haven't done this before.
New thing I'm going to try.
There are going to be
about eight of these.
They're going to be very brief.
They're going to happen at
the end of class, in class.
And you will do them on
your computer or your iPhone
using Google Forms.
If anybody doesn't have
a computer or an iPhone
they can bring to class
the days of those quizzes,
let us know after class and
we'll come up with a solution.
And the idea of
these is not to fish
out an obscure fact that was in
one of the reading assignments
and ding you on it.
I'm not interested in that.
The goal of this is just
to keep you up to date,
keep you doing the readings,
keep you up with the material.
And if you basically
are understanding what
you're reading and understanding
the lecture material--
maybe you glance at
it briefly before--
you should do fine
on the quizzes.
They're just kind
of reality checks
for us to know what people
are getting and not.
First quiz is February
20, blah, blah.
There is one longer
written assignment
that is not due with
the usual schedule,
with all of the other
things, to do near the end.
And in that one,
you will actually
design an experiment
in a particular area.
And that will be--
I don't know yet-- three to
five pages, something like that.
We'll give you more
details on exactly how you
want to organize this.
And it will be very
specific-- like,
state your exact
hypothesis, state
your exact experimental
design, et cetera.
And you'll get practice with
those things in advance.
Those are the grading
and requirements.
And this is the-- you have this
all in the syllabus in front
of you.
This is the lineup of topics.
But very briefly, let me try to
give you the arc of the class.
So this is the introduction.
Next time, we're going
to do just a teeny bit
of neuroanatomy.
There will be a teeny bit of
overlap with 900 and 901 there.
I'm going to whip through
it in very superficial form.
I'm doing that largely because
on the following class,
we have an amazing
privilege, which
is that one of the greatest
neuroscientists alive today,
Ann Graybiel's, will be doing
an actual brain dissection,
right here in this class,
right in front of you.
It's going to be awesome.
I can't wait.
It's an incredible privilege.
It will be a real human
brain, and you guys will be--
Ann will be here with
all her apparatus,
and you guys will
be clustered around.
And if it's this
many, god help us,
but we'll figure out
how to make it work.
I may-- let me just say, if
there are listeners in here,
I may have to tell
listeners they can't come,
because very sensitive about
not having too many people.
Stay tuned on that.
I haven't quite decided yet.
It depends how many people
are taking the class.
But it's going to be amazing.
And I want to remind
you of just some basics
so you're not asking her,
like, what is the hippocampus?
I should all know that, but
we'll just do bare basics.
And then we'll have
the dissection.
That will be great.
And also, another
thing to say is,
I mentioned that the subcortical
regions are going to get
short shrift in this class.
That's true.
But a lot of what you
see in the dissection
is the subcortical stuff.
Cortex is great but, it
kind of all looks the same.
You kind of can't say,
oh, that's this region.
That's the other region.
Well, you can, but it
doesn't look any different
from any other region.
That's where the subcortical
stuff will happen.
Then I'm going to do
a couple of lectures
that focus on high-level vision,
perceiving motion, and color,
and shape, and faces,
and scenes, and bodies,
and stuff like that.
And we will use those both
to teach you that content,
and also to teach you vast
array of methods in this field.
We will then have a
lecture on the kind
of debates about
the organization
of visual cortex in humans.
I have a particular view.
I'm very fond of views
that some patches of cortex
are very, very
functionally specific.
Not everyone believes that.
So I have assigned
readings of people
who have different views,
and we will consider that.
I will try to expose you
to the alternate views
and tell you why I'm teaching--
why I still believe mine,
but why other smart people
believe different things.
We will then move up the
system from perception,
and we will spend two meetings
talking about scene perception
and navigation.
You got a hint about what
an interesting area this is
from the story of Bob.
We'll consider more
what we've learned
from studies of patients
with brain damage,
from functional MRI, from
physiology in animals,
from cognitive science, from
the whole glorious menagerie
of methods to
understand navigation.
It's a really fascinating area.
In the two lectures after that,
we'll consider development.
How do you wire up a brain?
How much is present at birth?
What is specified in the genes?
What is learned?
And a lot of that will focus
on the navigation system
and the face system,
simply because that's
where there's a lot known.
We'll consider
some other things,
but those are two
areas where there's
super exciting work from just
the last three or four years.
That's what we'll
focus on there.
I'm then going to do a lecture
on brains in blind people.
How are they different?
How are they the same?
What does that tell us?
And then you have the midterm.
Then we're going to move
on and consider number.
How do you like instantly
know that that's three fingers
and that's two
without having to do
anything all that complicated?
And if I had 25 fingers
and held them up,
you would immediately get a
sense that it was about 25.
You might not know
if it was 22 or 28,
but you would know
it was about 25.
And there are
particular brain regions
that compute that for you.
And we will consider
all of that.
And there's a very rich
array of information
from studies of
infant cognition,
from animal behavior, from brain
imaging, from brain damage,
from single-unit physiology, and
from computation, all of which
inform our
understanding of number.
Those are my favorite
lectures, where
we can take one
domain of cognition
and inform it with
all of the methods.
And numbers are a
really great example.
Then we'll talk a
little bit about--
one of my TAS said,
call it neuroeconomics.
That will sound good.
But actually, what
I'm going to try to do
is sort of neuroeconomics.
But it will be about pleasure,
and pain, and reward,
and how we think
about those things.
And then that's down to April 3.
Just as a side note,
all of these things
are things that are pretty
similar between humans
and-- at least primates.
And some of them are
shared with rodents.
And most of the
things after that
are things that are
really uniquely human.
We'll be really moving away,
with less available animal
literature to inform the
stuff we're looking at,
because animals can't
do these things.
And so necessarily far from the
details of individual neurons
and circuits, but
there's still lots cool
that can be said about
how you understand speech,
how you appreciate music.
There will be a guest
lecture, just for fun,
on brain-machine interface
by Michael Cohen, who's
working in my lab
now, and who has
a great lecture on this topic.
Then we'll spend a couple
of lectures on language--
how you understand
and produce language,
and what the relevant
brain regions are,
what we know about
it from cognition,
and lots of other methods--
and what the relationship is
between language and thought.
Then we'll think about how
we think about other people.
This is called theory of mind--
how I can look out
at this lecture
and try to evaluate from
your facial expression.
Are they bored, sleepy,
overworked, fascinated,
excited?
All of this kind of
stuff that all of us
do moment-to-moment
in any conversation,
and that, yes, lecturers
are doing all of the time,
even if I know that you
guys have too much work,
and that's why
you're sleepy, and I
shouldn't take it personally.
I'm still noticing.
Anyway, then we'll go on
and consider brain networks.
Of course, brain
function doesn't
happen in just a single region,
even if we spend a lot of time
studying individual regions.
There's considerable
work trying to figure out
which sets of regions
work together,
and how could we discover that,
and what are those broader
networks of brain regions?
And then on May 6,
you will have turned
in your longer
written assignment
designing your own experiment.
And then on May 6, we will
work together in groups
to refine those experiments
and really hash out the details
so you actually know how
to design an experiment.
And then we will have this
guest lecture from my postdoc,
Katherina Dobbs, on deep nets
and what they can tell us
about cognition and brains.
And then we'll talk about
attention and awareness.
And then I'm not
totally sure what
we're going do in
the last class,
but what I'm voting for is
that the amazing TAs each
give a short talk on the
cool stuff they're doing.
But that's under discussion.
OK, that's the arc of the class.
Questions?
All clear?
Great.
Well, if I have
five more minutes,
maybe I'll do one
other little thing.
Let me try this.
You asked-- I'm going to try
to learn everybody's names,
but I'm not doing that
yet, because some of you
might not show up and I will
have wasted a whole piece
of my brain encoding it.
I'm just kidding.
But anyway, I remember
that you asked, are you
going to read current papers?
Yes, it is-- and you're right.
It's daunting.
But let me just say a little
bit about how to read papers.
This is not a stats course, and
we haven't prerequisited stats.
Neither is it a course
on the physics of MRI.
There will be parts
of every MRI paper
that have a lot of gobbledygook.
We scanned with this
scanning procedure.
We used this kind of scanner and
this kind of blah, blah, blah.
Lots of gobbledygook.
You guys don't need
to worry about that.
About the stats, it's
kind of a judgment call.
Everyone in here should have an
idea of what a P level means,
and I hope, a sense of what
a T-test is and an ANOVA.
If you don't, I should
probably tell you that offline,
because that's pretty basic.
And what a correlation is.
Beyond that, just use your
intuitions about those things.
And this is not of course
about understanding
the details of the stats
in each experiment.
There just isn't room to cover
all that in the substance
of the studies, as well.
When you read a paper--
for example, here's a paper--
a very old paper.
You come across this,
and it was like,
OK, here are all these words.
And it goes on for 20 pages.
And how do you even dig in?
Well, the way to dig in
is to start by saying,
what question is being
asked in this paper?
If the paper is
well written, you'll
be able to find that
in the abstract.
Blah, blah, blah, to study
the effect of face inversion
on the human fusiform face area.
We'll talk about
that more later.
But if you fish
through the abstract,
you should be able to find
what question is being asked.
And it's the first thing
you should figure out
about a paper.
You don't necessarily
read a paper start to--
beginning through the end.
I think it's better to start
with this list of questions
in your head and look for the
answers to those questions.
Second question.
What did they find?
If the abstract is
well written, you
can find that in the
abstract as well.
Signal intensity from
the fusiform face area
was reduced when grayscale faces
were presented upside down.
Kind of boring, but there it is.
That's the finding
of this paper.
What is the interpretation?
In other words, who cares?
Why-- who cares about this?
If you look in here,
in the abstract,
FFA responds to
faces per se rather
than to the low-level
features present in faces.
We'll talk more about
what that means.
You guys have an assignment
about that-- probably,
several assignments about
that kind of question.
Next question you want to
ask yourself is, what is
the design of this experiment?
Often, for this, you have
to go beyond the abstract.
And I should say, for even
these earlier questions,
sometimes you won't find
them in the abstract.
That just means the abstract
is not well written.
But that exists.
To get the design--
like, what exactly did they do?
Usually, you have to fit
in what exactly was done,
and how were the data analyzed?
You need to fish farther.
You need to fish around
other parts of the paper.
And of course, all
of those questions--
I just said, what question--
I circled this part.
But there are many
levels to one question.
You can get more on, why is that
inverted question important?
You look through, usually, in
the introduction to the paper.
Does the FFA respond
to faces per se,
or to a confounding
visual feature which
tends to be present in faces?
Second, is it true that
inverted faces cannot engage
face-specific mechanisms?
Blah, blah, blah.
That gives you a
little more background
on what the question is.
There are different
levels of depth.
These are all things
you want to be looking
for when you read a paper.
What exactly was done?
We measured MRI
responses in the FFA
to upright and inverted faces.
I don't expect you to
understand all of this.
These are just giving
you, schematically,
how you proceed when
you're reading a paper.
More on the interpretation,
or who cares?
This result would show that
face-specific mechanisms are
engaged only or predominantly
by upright faces,
blah, blah, blah.
You can fish through
for those things.
The point is to have those
questions in your head
when you read a paper.
It's much more easy and
engaging to read something
if you have an agenda
when you read it.
Your agenda, in reading
scientific papers,
is to answer those
questions for yourself.
More stuff.
What was the design and logic?
Often, that's deep
in the methods.
You have to fish
around and find it.
There will be some set of
conditions and designs.
We'll talk more about
all this kind of stuff.
What exactly was done,
blah, blah, more details.
And this is an example of
the kind of gobbledygook
that you can ignore.
Subjects were scanned on
a 1 and 1/2 T scanner.
And there are all these--
here's an example of
said gobbledygook.
You can ignore
this, in this class.
Every method will have
different kinds of gobbledygook.
This is MRI gobbledygook.
You can ignore it.
It matters a lot, but not here.
What else?
How are the data analyzed?
If you look in the--
sometimes, there's a data
analysis section, or a results
section, or a methods
section, that will tell you.
You can find that,
figure it out.
What was the finding?
Here's more on the finding.
Again, you just fish
through for these things.
The point is just, when
you're reading a paper,
it's not necessarily--
what I do is, I read the
title, I read the abstract.
And then I start answering
those questions for myself.
And sometimes, at that point,
I'm skipping to figures.
I'm skipping to methods.
Any of that is fine.
Don't feel like you need
to understand each word,
especially deep in the methods.
I don't know.
Was that helpful at all?
We'll try it, and you guys
will give me feedback,
and if it works, great.
And if not, we'll do more
on how to read papers.
All right, it's 12:25.
See you on Monday.